republican senator mitt romney
was confronted yesterday in an airport
it looks like uh
dca in washington dc from the video that
we are going to play
you all know i didn't vote for mitt
romney in 2012. i voted for barack obama
you all know
mitt romney is a conservative republican
completely not in line with my politics
but mitt romney
in this particular confrontation with
the complete and utter
loon sounds eminently reasonable
and completely respectful and polite
even when he really has no reason to be
given how he's being treated in this
video you are going to see
the end result of the heat romney has
been taking from the right
from the pro-trump right because while
mitt romney is a right-wing religious
republican
he has refused to indulge donald trump
in some of his authoritarian insanity
mitt romney
didn't vote for trump in the
presidential election mitt romney on one
of two impeachment counts actually did
vote to convict mitt romney in the
senate
and in this video mitt romney is
accosted in the airport and he's way
more polite than many people would have
been to this woman when mitt romney
is the calming voice of reason in a
conversation
you know things are crazy and that they
are with this
maga cult that is here and is likely
going to be with us for some period of
time so let's look at the video
we joined the video with mitt romney
sitting by himself at the airport
with his mask on as required approached
by a maskless person we might call her a
maskless holy karen if we wanted some
kind of name
let's join the video how you doing
don't tell me what to do please put your
mask on it's it's required by law in the
circle i'm standing six feet away i'm
sorry
okay i'll tell you what because you know
what i'm going to go ahead and do it
because i want to have a chat with you
so first of all i don't need a mask
because i'm six feet away
you're in the airport the air airports
require masks
lady and that's just a microcosm of how
they make up the rules as they
as they go along as they want them to be
let's continue
why aren't you supporting president
trump i do support the things president
trump does that i think i agree with
you're not supporting him i'm sorry i do
agree with many of the things he
is for and i support those things are
you going to support him in the uh
the fraudulent votes this is the
election why not
because yes you're my remarks
it's going to be a real one i'm sorry
can you say that again it's a long
story but the we have a constitution the
constitutional process is clear i'll
follow the constitution and i'll explain
what we meet in congress so mitt romney
has asked
why won't he support trump trying
to steal the election and romney says
because we have a constitution and you
would think
that these constitutional fetishists if
they were actually committed to
constitutionality
would respect that in mitt romney but no
it actually makes her
more angry and this is one of my
favorite moments
well you haven't supported him and you
didn't even support him in the election
no i did not why for reasons i explained
at the time
you were voted in as a conservative to
represent the conservative
constituents period actually that's not
how the constitution works
now that's fascinating for a few reasons
she says
you were voted in as a conservative
republican to represent conservatives
and there there's two things there first
as mitt points out
he's elected to represent his entire
constituency
and to defend the constitution stealing
an election that trump lost is not
constitutional
but there's also this idea that even a
conservative republican like mitt romney
isn't really conservative unless he's
trying to steal the election for trump
when in reality there's nothing
conservative about
trying to execute an unconstitutional
coup when trump lost
the election let's watch more it is
you're voted in to represent us you work
for us
am i wrong i work for the people of utah
exactly and i am from utah but you're
not the only one i voted i know there's
a lot of people that didn't vote for you
we'll make sure that one of course will
be part of it
you admit it you know it you know it's
coming they didn't want you in there
anyway so to be honest with you i
wouldn't be surprised if
if you weren't even if you weren't even
voted in legally
so there mitt romney starts walking uh
but
again two more things to note first
the woman and a guy also there say
you're going to get primary like a
threat
and mitt romney says of course that's
fine that's that's the process
they're threatening him with something
that he supports being part of the
system and and
it's not praise of mitt romney's
political views but
he at least has not become so divorced
from just the the fundamentals of how
politics works
he's a that's not really i deserve to be
primary
that's the system being primary that's
what we do
and then the woman throws in you weren't
even voted in legally
and that's really scary that's scary
because
it's now completely acceptable in the
maga cult
to off-handedly say about any elected
official that you don't like
or who doesn't support what you want to
do in this case try to steal the
election
it's now acceptable to say you weren't
even voted in legally
i've never heard any question about the
legality
uh or or um integrity
of the election in which mitt romney won
and that's the long-term danger that i
spoke about with sam cedar last night as
we were watching the georgia
senate results come in the normalization
and the degradation of our politics
where with trump saying it was rigged
and i won
many of his followers fell for it and
then now they apply it to any election
of any politician that they don't like
you weren't even elected legally
and then lastly once he got on the plane
things weren't much better for mitt
romney
trump people starting to chant traitor
so anyway it must have been a beautiful
fight for a flight there for uh for for
mitt romney so
democrats held the house in 2020 they
won the senate
and won the white house but this is
going to be a very very long
two years the cultists are going to be
with us the question is how
engaged will they be as i mentioned
earlier and
we will be with you and following it